man's Duty versus feminist narrative
this is important let's go to that 352.
we have about
three more that I want to get to and
then I'm going to sum up
for example the feminist narrative is
that I'm a controlling man who wants
control over women the actual truth is
I'm a protective man who wants to
protect and being a man in a position of
protecting is not always a good thing I
feel indebted and have a duty to myself
and my honor meaning that if I'm walking
down the street with a beautiful woman
and three men want to attack her I have
to risk my life now I can't live my life
letting my wife get gang raped on a
[ __ ] Street and running away I can't
take it as a man so I have to now die
I have to die or try I have no choice so
but that's my duty but they'll they'll
ignore that part they'll ignore the part
where I risked my life right and they'll
say oh but you just want to be
controlling results no no I have a duty
to protect I'm calmer Under Pressure
because I've been in more unfortunate
situations I've had more trauma in my
life which has trained me to be more
calm Under Pressure I would hate to meet
a woman who's been through as much
trauma as I have that's not the kind of
that would make her a good woman I don't
think women need to draw on that level I
don't want women who've been stabbed
there's no need for that but I have been
through it so I think that in my
experience extrapolation that men who
are successful a lot of them have been
through enough we can trust them more in
a high pressure situation and like I
said this comes with massive
responsibility this comes with massive
detriments and downsides right and and
the feminist like no you're controlling
it's all about controlling it's about
Duty there was no feminist on the
Titanic then then men can die there's no
Eminence to this day in Ukraine
the Ukrainian women can leave you'll see
them partying in Warsaw and Prague
Ukrainian men can't leave the country
they're dying in a ditch yeah I mean
they can't you just see why they hate
this guy though
they hate this guy because he's so he's
so right on so many things and it's it's
stuff that you don't you know oftentimes
in the modern world people who've kind
of ingested the bias of Academia and
ingested modern feminism you don't want
to hear the reality but how refreshing
honestly to hear a guy say that it's his
duty to protect you that if you're
walking down a street and he's there and
he's with someone who he considers his
girl that it's his job to risk his life
at one point he says in the video I have
to die for you know and he means it I
believe that he means it how
unbelievably refreshing to see a guy
like that in a world where everyone
wants you to embrace the guy who runs
with you who sees the day during like oh
my let's call the cops let's get out of
here the guy who's just as afraid of the
tarantula As You Are
they want that they want that dynamic
because again you have to castrate those
guys in order to weaken Society at large
in order to create a class of dependence
that is growing and growing and growing
we know that we've established that but
how refreshing to hear somebody talk
like that this guy's got to drive them
mad
he's got to drive all the guys who are
less than mad the guys who don't want
that responsibility they're lazy they
don't feel confident in themselves the
guys who who don't don't feel they'd be
able to step up to the plate he's gonna
drive them crazy he's got to drive the
women crazy who are out there being like
I don't need a man I could go to sperm
bank but really no really know in their
heart of hearts that they do want one
and they would benefit so much from a
true you know marriage or a situation
where they could lean on men for the
things that men should be able to
provide and are good at very refreshing
I have to say to hear a guy speak so
openly about the duty to protect I love
it
um I'm not embarrassed to say that and I
love a guy who says my jobs take care of
my family what is wrong with that if
there's something wrong with that you
got to do some self-reflection what are
you looking for what are you really
looking for a guy that says oh no I
don't know
let's just split the bill you know I
mean is that appealing to you it's not
you know it you know it so have you been
programmed to think this this is bad
really sit and absorb what he's saying
and make a decision for yourself does it
really bother you all that much I'm not
bothered by that at all to be perfectly
honest and I'm sitting here as someone
who I do feel is empowered who has the
the job and the microphone and I'm like
I love a guy who gets to be a guy
gets to do what he is supposed to do and
what makes him feel good to do if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
foreign
[Music]